i love this you just know that at that
army of the dead screwing there's a
whole bunch of people just like
two weeks
right there with them do you like don't
worry i'm watching your movie i really
do but i also want to ask you much
i'm gonna try and not make it about that
but i need to make it about that
[Music]
what is happening there reject negay
thanos is trending on twitter
oh boy what else is trinidad today
speaking of segway well that was
it fascinating discovery apparently zack
snyder
has released an image or he was at a q a
and he unveiled an actual
look of wayne t carr as green lantern
if you guys don't know the story i'll
make it really quick the scene that was
martian man hunter at the end of zack
snyder's justice league that was
going to be green lantern that was zack
snyder's original intent they shot it in
his driveway he even told wayne t
carr this scene might not make it in the
movie
eventually wb did say please don't do
this because uh they want to introduce
their own jon stewart and they want to
make their own announcement about it on
the day they do it and they do have the
hbo max green lantern series anyway he
was at a q a
i don't know someone just asked him and
he went ahead and showed it so i was
like
it's a short clip so yeah let's just see
what's going on here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what
full of people look at that well i love
how he even took time to like
look back at it and be like that's
pretty cool image and i love his face
the whole time he's doing it
oh the wonder
this is an exclusive i know you're gonna
[ __ ] bricks over
yeah that does look pretty badass oh and
then obviously
i'm sure he has his own little scene
already edited ready to kind of just
insert into the movie
or if you wanted to just release the
scene online this was a case though
where because he seems like he's been
pretty outspoken about disagreements
that he's had with the studios even in
the process of getting this one released
but he seemed
understanding with this so then they
compromised a martian manhunter but
what's funny about looking at this
image like the suit does look really
cool and i and i hope
actually more than for zack snyder i
hope for wayne t carr this scene gets to
be
shown this looks like it takes place
during the night
yeah where's the martian manhunter scene
was during the day
i mean it looks like there's a full-on
like aurora borealis behind it yeah
which i mean props to zack snyder's
driveway just because it's like what a
picturesque place but yeah especially if
ostensibly won't be any continuation of
the snyder verse from now on i feel like
if this is here
i almost feel like they should just put
the rest of it out slowly over time and
just
let the final remnants go into the world
we can all geek out over them and then
yeah the honor
to the time spent will have been paid
then yeah it's like you won't have this
stuff collecting dust on a shelf you
know
sadly forever it looks striking and and
it would be cool to actually see the
scene in its completion
see zack snyder's take on green hurt
anybody
you know like we already got the
completed film maybe well after
wb's new series is up and running and
it's already established itself you know
maybe then put it out
this is part of the canons of all the
other comic books things that didn't get
made like the superman nicholas cage
movie you know do you want to see this
green lantern scene released it does
look pretty badass that looks awesome
that does look awesome and i hope for
wayne t car that scene gets to get
released
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button and uh yeah
catch you guys soon